le grand mort jean-paul-riopelle est
inspiré par ses paysages à couper le
souffle
ses inspirations se mêlaient de partout
au site commun un rêve
l'éclair sujet le musée des beaux-arts
lui consacre une grande exposition
riôtel à la rencontre des territoires
nordiques et des cultures autochtones
on y présentera entre autres deux
oeuvres jamais exposé publiquement au
québec on perçoit ce moment et à
quelques hommes étant un homme de nature
l'exposition pour sa part présentent
également un homme de culture donc un
homme qui à l'udc s'est intéressé en
contre aux cultures autochtones
dès les années 70 prix opel s'est rendu
dans le grand nord pour chasser pêcher
le nord l'habiter ces voyages finalement
été très court c'était quoi une semaine
deux semaines donc il a fait pendant
quelques années mais c'était très
condensée mais ce qui leur pend
ressortait c'était vraiment énormément
d'heures je veux dire ça l'habitait
pendant très longtemps
visionnaire rehab elle s'est intéressée
à la question autochtone bien avant
qu'on parle de l'appropriation
culturelle
on a fait le pari de présenter ses
oeuvres influencé par l'art autochtone
un peu pour soumettre la question au
public à savoir c'est utile
d'appropriation culturel et que donc que
devons nous en pensée aujourd'hui le
musée des beaux-arts de montréal a
récemment annoncé qu'il renonçait à
construire une aile consacrée au peintre
mais sa fille affirme qu'il y aura
d'autres projets pour honorer le 100e
anniversaire de naissance du maître en
2023 on a toujours eu des plantes
plusieurs plans sur le sujet ce sont les
t1 en attendant la réouverture des
musées l'exposition est présentée en
ligne gratuitement jusqu'au en janvier
avec l'hiver qui est à nos portes cette
exposition pourrait bien nous
réconcilier avec notre nordicité ici
n'est bien lexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]